piège pour tous les autres il faut avoir
le courage de faire le constat que
l'europe à 27 noeuds permet de réaliser
le vrai consensus que sur des sujets
mineurs ou à la mode
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 22 avril le pic
de la troisième vague semble derrière
nous mais jean castex a prévenu d'emblée
le niveau de circulation se réduit mais
reste très élevé si le couvre feu est
maintenu au moins jusqu'à la mi mai la
rentrée se fera bien le 26 avril pour
les maternelles et les élémentaires avec
le déploiement des tests salivaires mais
aussi des autotests pour les personnels
de l'éducation nationale puis les
lycéens olive et veyran lui tente de
rassurer sur le vaccin astrazeneca un
sommet virtuel sur le climat qui marque
le retour des etats-unis dans la lutte
contre le réchauffement à l'initiative
de joe biden qui met en garde contre le
coût de l'inaction une thématique
consensuel qui a vu de nombreux chefs
d'état s'exprimaient dans vladimir
poutine
si jim pays ou encore emmanuel macron le
président américain qui veut réduire de
50% les gaz à effet de serre dans son
pays d'ici à 2030
[Musique]
lire poutine qui se dit prêt à recevoir
à moscou à n'importe quel moment son
homologue ukrainien volodimir zelensky
pour évoquer leurs relations bilatérales
moscou annonce met en terme à des
exercices militaires au crime et le
ministre russe de la défense a décrété
la fin des contrôles de préparation au
combat
il estime que les forces armées ont
démontré leur capacité à défendre le
pays
sergueï choïgou qui dit surveillait le
déploiement de l'otan
[Musique]
conférence de presse de jean castex dont
tout à l'heure sur la situation
sanitaire le pic de la troisième pack
sang derrière nous mais le premier
ministre a prévenu comme d'habitude si
le niveau de circulation se réduit il
reste tout de même très élevé le couvre
feu reste maintenue au moins jusqu'à la
mi mai pour plus de précisions nous
retrouvons tout de suite en direct david
kelly phare directe du ministère de la
santé bonsoir david un point presse
hebdomadaire quasiment sans surprise ce
soir
oui stéphanie c'est celle où un sans
surprise une visibilité finalement
presque identique qu'avant ce point
presse hebdomadaire pour les français
jean castex a d'abord confirmé la
réouverture à des écoles dès ce lundi
pour les crèches maternelles et
primaires un dépistage massif devait
être mis en place avec notamment les
déploiements à des autos ce test et des
tests salivaires dans les établissements
scolaires un choix assumé par l'exécutif
est une fierté d'avoir répondu aux
objectifs affichés
1 concernant l'éducation nationale y
écouter le premier ministre nous en
réalisions 250000 par semaine fin mars
nous en proposerons 400000 par semaine à
la reprise avec la perspective
d'atteindre 600 mille tests d'ici la mi
mai nous concentrerons ce dispositif de
dépistage dans les départements où
l'incidence est la plus élevée
en complément des tests salivaires la
grande nouveauté de la reprise sera le
déploiement des autotests il s'agit d'un
prélèvement nasal
mais beaucoup plus simple et léger que
pour les tests pcr et dont le résultat
est connu en 15 minutes
jean michel blanquer le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a par la suite
détaillé
le protocole sanitaire territorialisée
qui sera mise en place dès lundi david
les écoles largement abordés durant ce
point presse mais les français espérait
également avoir plus de précisions pour
sur le retour à une vie normale
oui elle a aussi stéphanie encore
beaucoup de flou ans même si elle vous
l'avais dit la situation à sanitaire
s'améliore le premier ministre s'est
montré très prudent et n'a rien dévoilé
ou presque adieu calendrier du
déconfinement néanmoins l'exécutif
promet de lever les restrictions aux
déplacements le 3 mai prochain ce sera
la fin à des attestations et à de
l'interdiction des déplacements
pour ce qui est du couvre-feu en
revanche le gouvernement a confirmé que
celui-ci restera quoi qu'il arrive en
vigueur jusqu'à la mi-mai pour la
réouverture des terrasses des bars et
restaurants de celle des lieux culturels
l'échéance à la mi mai et confirmé
écouter à partir du 3 mai également
nous pourrons lever les contraintes de
déplacement en journée est envisagée
sous réserve de l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire
un nouveau train de réouverture autour
de la mi mai qui pourrait commencer par
les commerces certaines activités
culturelles et sportives et les
terrasses
cette liste n'est pas définitivement
fixée elle sera assortie de conditions
particulières le cas échéant je le
disais territorialisée qui évolueront au
fil des étapes
voilà aussi à beaucoup de prudence à
cause notamment des variants sud
africains brésiliens ou indiens un
durcissement des conditions d'entrée sur
le territoire pour tous les voyageurs
issus de ces pays a été annoncé
également par le premier ministre et
dernier point abordé ce soir la campagne
de vaccination avec encore une fois une
défense sans relâche d'astrazeneca
sans relâche c'est le mot exact
stéphanie tous les membres du
gouvernement présents ce soir ont
prononcé le mot à sera à zenica jean
castex a d'abord à rappeler que
l'exécutif rattraper son retard dans le
calendrier vaccinal initial là aussi
avec une certaine forme
d'autosatisfaction et cette phrase nous
affichons un rythme de vaccination par
avril et plus rapide d'europe l'objectif
de vacciner 20 millions de français à
l'abri mais et 30 millions à la mi juin
est toujours d'actualité
et pour cela et bien il faut convaincre
les français que astrazeneca est sans
danger puisque les douze peine à trouver
des receveurs volontaire le chef du
gouvernement a donc tenté de redonner du
crédit aux vaccins britannique au
suédois pointé du doigt pour ses effets
indésirables et notamment à quelques cas
de thrombose olivier ferrand a pour cela
a tenté de nuancer en utilisant des
comparatifs de la vie quotidienne
écoutez le ministre de la santé dans de
très rares cas il peut provoquer des
thromboses c'est à dire la formation de
petits cailloux qui peuvent aller
bouchée des haines qui peuvent aller
boucher la circulation veineuse et
provoquer pour le coup des effets
indésirables plus graves mais ils sont
très rares c'est cinq cas environ pour
un million de personnes vaccinées
je vous donnais une comparaison si vous
prenez l'avion pour traverser
l'atlantique
vous avez un risque également de faire
des thromboses parce que vous allez être
moins mobiles et ce risque
si vous traversez l'atlantique en avion
il est 50 fois plus élevé que si vous
faites d'actionner par astra zeneca ça
permet quand même je crois de
relativiser les choses
minimiser les risques encourus pour
convaincre un maximum de français de se
faire vacciner avec astrazeneca c'était
l'objectif annoncé est affichée de
l'exécutif
ce soir hormis ça vous l'aurez compris
il faudra patienter jusqu'à la prise de
parole des manuels macron pour avoir un
calendrier
la plus nette plus claire du
déconfinement lorsque viendra le temps
des bonnes nouvelles
merci david california en est loin et à
ce propos d'ailleurs on ne prend pas de
temps que ça l'avion donc pour reprendre
les métaphores de ministre de la santé
pas beaucoup de risques en ce moment de
ce point de vue
merci à vous et cette conférence de
presse du gouvernement on en parle avec
nos invités place un autre décryptage ce
soir
avec nous ce soir benjamin amar
professeur d'histoire porte parole cgt
94 bonsoir benjamin ma vo côté francis
palombes président avait confédération
des commerçants bonsoir vous francs 6
plombier
enfin alexis poulain éditorialise
bonsoir alexis poulain alors les
conférences de presse de jean castex
c'est devenu le rendez vous
incontournable du jeudi avant de
recueillir l'avis des secteurs concernés
par ces annonces ce soir alexis poulain
globalement que vous a inspiré ce cru du
soir aulas alors c'est vrai elle nous
manquait presque un ces conférences
hebdomadaires ils sont passés maîtres
dans l'art de prendre beaucoup de temps
pour dire pas grand chose des annonces
qu'on attendait pas puisqu'il n'y en a
pas eu quasiment le fait que les écoles
vont rouvrir à date fixe comme l'a dit
emmanuel macron ils sont là pour meubler
pour boucher pour donner finalement
quelques éléments de langage celui du
soir s'était renforcé un des mesures
renforcées on l'a entendu sinon c'est le
flou total et puis ils n'appellent délit
mais ce soir je souhaite un bon
anniversaire à d'autres pistes de la
santé s'était et 41 ans d'olivier vers
ans aujourd'hui voilà c'était peut-être
pour ça qu'il ya eu cette conférence de
presse histoire de fêter le coup un peu
différemment avec jean michel blanquer
remise de l'éducation qui étaient là
également on a l'impression que tout est
là pour gagner du temps pour faire
croire qu'il se passe quelque chose et
puis surtout pour écouler les stocks de
vaccin parce que clairement dans
quelques temps les vaccins strazeele et
qu'un risque d'être périmés et il faut
les injecté avant cette catastrophe
parce que là les 20 millions et les 30
millions enfin on va en parler sans
doute des objectifs vaccinaux ne seront
jamais atteinte dans ce cadre là oui on
en parlera dans quelques instants alexis
on va essayer détaillé les points
importants quand même de cette
conférence de presse un rentrée des
classes donc bien confirmé lundi avec un
protocole très strict et un renforcement
massif des tests quatre cent mille tests
salivaires dans les écoles élémentaires
et le nouvel outil a enfin l'autotest 1
pour les lycées je vous propose
d'écouter
olivier vers en vente vous faire réagir
benjamin hama et nous avons désormais
conformément à l'avis du conseil
scientifique les autotests qui viennent
compléter cette stratégie de dépistage
c'est un outil qui va être utile qui
complète notre arsenal existants mais
qui ne va pas remplacer les tests pcr ni
les tests antigénique c'est une très
belle opportunité de nous aider à
maîtriser davantage l'épidémie alors que
nous travaillons à pouvoir rouvrir
progressivement les lieux de vie à
compter de la mi-mai
depuis le temps qu'on en parle et ça y
est on les a maintenant c'est autotests
vous voilà bah rassurer ma jamar vous
allez pouvoir vous auto testé avec les
lycéens pour reprendre ce que dit
monsieur poulin je sais pas si c'était
la fête d'anniversaire de monsieur
virant ou si c'était encore une fois une
mauvaise version d marrakech du rire
mais moi je n'en peux plus de ces de ses
conférences de presse qui sont des
exercices de communication
c'est insupportable alors écoutez je
sais pas si vous soulevez ces familles
pour mais on avait déjà discuté des
tests il ya déjà quelques mois de cela
où j'étais très dubitatif il m'avait dit
mais c'est vrai mais vous m'aviez dit
mais attendez c'est à la rentrée et
c'est alors à la rentrée on a vu ce que
ça avait donné ce qui se passe c'est que
alors moi j'entends les chiffres
astronomiques du premier ministre mais
moi dans mon établissement scolaire le
moment du dépistage a été ridicule pour
une raison très simple il faut l'accord
des familles
il ya énormément de familles qui n'ont
pas donné leur accord
dans le monde réel c'est comme ça que ça
se passe en macro ni dans dans
l'hyperespace macro nist ya une version
est dans le réel dans la vraie vie il ya
une autre version de test du papa de
test je connais plein de colère il n'y a
pas eu de test du tout hein
vous avez raison nous celle où je vous
dis il ya eu une campagne à maman de
deux de test mais ça a été ridicule
parce que il ya énormément de familles
qui n'avaient pas fait leur tour qu'ils
n'avaient pas donné leur accord
voilà et ça c'est entre ce que vous
dites c'est à dire des hongrois où il ya
rien
et des endroits où il ya eu mais la
réponse des familles a été extrêmement
marginale eh ben on est dans un délire
et la nouvelle trouvaille c'est
l'autotest alors c'est quoi
à la rentrée moi je vais arriver avec
mes élèves et on va tous se faire une
séance d'auto test dans les narines
sincèrement vraiment je ne sais plus
quoi dire moi les bras m'en tombent
je sais le gouvernement kamoulox chaque
semaine il ya une nouvelle idée là
j'entendais ce que vous disiez vous ils
sont en train d'évoquer la fin du dd
enfin le fait qu'on puisse à nouveau se
déplacer de manière inter régional et en
même temps il met en place des
quarantaines enfin je pourrais te dire
après nous avoir dit pendant des mois
qu'il pouvait pas mettre en place des
quarantaines il ya des signaux
contradictoires en permanence on dit une
chose une semaine plus tard on dit autre
chose et ça sur tous les sujets je pense
que les français sont définitivement
totalement déboussolée avec ce
gouvernement
alors il ya pire y aller les commerçants
c'est encore moins franco maire son
activité culturelle sport et terrasses
ouvriront me mais si et seulement si
c'est le problème du si la situation le
permet francis ce pas lambie comment les
commerçants vivent t-il ce manque de
visibilité
vous attendez j'imagine autre chose
peut-être ce soir écoutez madame je vais
vous répondre
un petit peu à l'image de mes collègues
concernant ce soir nous concernant pas
d'annoncé fracassante
le président de la république avait
commencé à donner un calendrier et on
avait oui que à la mi mai une
réouverture était envisageable
ça semble vouloir être le cas nous y
tenons plus que particulièrement parce
que certains de mon commerçant je porte
les très petites entreprises sont à
l'épuisement
alors c'est vrai que j'ai eu peut-être
j'ai vécu cette arabité un exercice
peut-être plus probants et surtout plus
intéressant j'ai créé j'ai eu
l'autorisation et d'un webinaire de deux
heures avec le ministère de la laine
grise et et de son conseiller
mais bien sûr j'ai demandé à ce que nous
passions en revue toutes les mesures
d'accompagnement et ce qui a été fait et
beaucoup de questions ont été posées
cash par les entreprises que je porte
que je représente
il y avait plus de soixante dix
représentants d'entreprises et de
fédérations et effectivement ce qui
ressort c'est que au niveau des aides
peut être certainement quand même le
paysage est un peu plus rassurants que
l'aspect sanitaire parce que un renfort
des aides est prévue avec des
aménagements nouveaux on n'est pas au
bout de toutes nos demandes et je le
précise également mais disons que
c'était incontournable c'est inévitable
si il y avait rupture ou retrait sysmans
retrait des aides ce serait la
catastrophe
alors bien évidemment il ya des
commerçants qui ne n'ont pas pu attendre
jusqu'à maintenant pour résister
malheureusement il ya eu de trop de
licenciement pour l'instant et surtout
de faillite
mais pour autant
l'inquiétude était grande alors les
commerçants veulent réouvrir à tout prix
l'incertitude de ces derniers jours les
a mis en colère je le dis également
ils voulaient en savoir un peu plus lent
sable pas beaucoup plus certains m'ont
demandé de demander la réouverture au 3
mai je ne leur ai dit que c'était peine
perdue
compte tenu car même que nous devons
toujours considéré en tant que citoyens
responsables la spécialité mais je pense
que la réouverture autour du 15 mai nous
préférerions que ce soit le plus tôt
possible
cissé à l'ascension cissé avant si c'est
à partir du 10 mai ce serait encore
mieux
je n'y compte pas trop mais il ya quand
même la notion d'ouverture et maintenant
nous allons rester très attachée à un
calendrier précis qui va être confirmée
par le président de la république
apparemment très très prochainement et
nous sommes en train de tout mettre un
oeuvre bien sûr d'accepter certaines
contraintes mais deux c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire parce que jean castex
a précisé à la liste n'est
définitivement pas fixé sera assorti de
conditions particulières le cacher on
territorialisée qui évolue au fil des
étapes on aura l'occasion de préciser ça
c'est très flou quand même alexis
poulain on imagine que pour certains
c'est compliqué parce que oui les aides
perdure m'enfin y en a qui ont le
couteau sous la gorge c'est on imagine
catastrophique pour beaucoup de
commerçants et notamment des
restaurateurs qu'on a souvent entendu
ici même un oui non mais vous vous
imaginez comment se fait balader depuis
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois mais
maintenant disons avec toujours ces
objectifs qui sont données qui ne sont
jamais tenues c'était 4 à 6 semaines il
y a huit semaines de cela c'était dans
un mois c'est maintenant me mais on
parle de 800 mille emplois on parle de
d'entrepreneurs qui ne savent pas
comment l'avenir va être faire part des
d'aussi qui vont être débranchées
progressivement bruno le maire qui
provisionne déjà
est à 8 milliards de non remboursement
des prêts garantis par l'état
c'est-à-dire des faillites
on parle de plus de 120000 faillite qui
sont déjà en préparation avec les
liquidateurs et une réforme de la gs qui
va faire que en plus l'argent qu'ils
payaient les salariés va payer les
liquidateurs plutôt que les salariés
tout ça est en cours et rien n'est fait
pour éviter le mur des faillites éviter
le mur de l'incertitude parce que pour
beaucoup de restaurateurs ça veut dire
quoi
recommencer à zéro avec l'incertitude
aussi du retour des gens finalement
restaurant le fait qu'il n'y aura pas de
touristes comme les autres d'année même
si on ouvre pour la saison estivale
ce ne sera pas une saison estivale comme
les autres donc elles seront les aides
qui jusqu'à quand et le combien ça coûte
au final qui va le payer c'est le couac
il va nous en coûter quoi qu'il va en
coûter aux entreprises et je crois que
le la colère elle elle est réelle
l'agacement il est il est permanent et
là avec ses conférences de presse qui
nous sortent toujours les mêmes choses
avec dû renforcer avec des tests avec
des stratégies mais improvisé sur des
coin de nappe avec les cabinets de
conseil pour nous prendre pour des
hamsters un coup on sort de la cage un
cours entre qu'est-ce qu'on prépare
réellement je crois que là aujourd'hui
tout est misé sur une stratégie de
vaccination avec ses 20 millions de
doses 30 millions de doses pour dire
qu'on va retrouver impotence d'une
potentielle vie normale mais ce ne sera
jamais une vie normale on aura le
derrière ce top cow vide tout senti
comme une je sais pas comment ça
s'appellera le fameux pass sanitaire
peut-être pour aller au restaurant
mais on marche sur la tête on aura le
masque à peu près partout tout le temps
puisque le vaccin ne n'empêche pas les
gestes barrières et puis on aura combien
de rappel par an il sera elle prépare
déjà le rappel pour la fin de l'année et
puis chaque année dure à des rappels
alors ça veut dire quoi que le monde
d'avant il est mort et enterré et qu'on
va vivre maintenant sous couvre-feu
permanent avec ce pass sanitaire avec
cette incertitude permanente
voilà la question auquel aujourd'hui je
crois aucun responsable politique en
europe ne peut répondre particulièrement
ici en france où on marche vraiment sur
la tête puisque ça n'a été que des
ordres contradictoires et et des amendes
et des amendes parce que à 19 heures il
fallait rentrer chez soi le couvre-feu à
19 heures bon je crois qu'on peut
arrêter il fait jour il fait bon on va
peut-être décaler un peu partout la
raison c'est manifestement
moi j'aimerais moi j'aimerais j'aimerais
savoir quel est l'intérêt de ce
couvre-feu maintenant aujourd'hui voilà
donc je crois qu'à un moment il va
falloir poser des câbles et marne et
alexis le double m6 fait n'importe c'est
évidemment la vaccination parce qu on a
vu comment ça se passait au royaume uni
et un calendrier qui a pu être respecté
et donner surtout grâce à une campagne
de vaccination réussi malgré tout
olivier verront reste optimiste et nous
annonce des chiffres 1 30 millions à la
mi juin le problème on le connaît aussi
en france et la confiance par rapport à
l'astra est née cas et alors là on sent
que tout le monde rame
l'astra zé meka qui est sur toutes les
lèvres je vous propose d'écouter jean
castex beaucoup de vaccins ont été
développés ils sont utilisés dans les
différents pays du monde
seul un petit nombre ont été autorisés
en france et en europe sur la base d'une
évaluation et d'un suivi rigoureux qui
nous permettent d'en garantir
l'efficacité et la sécurité
c'est le cas du vaccin astrazeneca dont
l' agence européenne du médicament et la
haute autorité de santé françaises ont
encore réaffirmé récemment qu'il était
aussi efficace contre les formes sévères
que le finder ou le moderna je vous
rappelle que nous comptons encore 11
millions de personnes de plus de 55 ans
qui n'ont pas encore été vaccinés
j'ai 55 ans et je me suis vacciné avec
l'astra zeneca comme 200 millions de
personnes dans le monde
benjamin amara vos collègues qui sont
désormais prioritaires de plus de 55 ans
vous leur conseillerais de l'effet se
faire vacciner avec ce sérum parce que
c'est vrai que on en a en france a pour
être l'une des premières solutions mais
y'a voilà beaucoup de défiance europe
c'est alors d'abord moi je suis
syndicaliste et enseignant je suis pas
médecin donc je vais conseiller
personnes par contre je vais vous dire
une chose très simple
moi j'ai eu donc locaux vides sous une
forme grave
et comme je fais de l'hypertension
artérielle justement je suis
particulièrement sensible sur sur cette
maladie donc j'ai cherché à me faire
vacciner rapidement
mon médecin m'a fait un certificat et il
m'a dit
une chose monsieur amar vous avez 45 ans
surtout vous ne vous faites pas vacciner
à l'astra zeneca ça c'est aussi encore
une fois ce qu'on dit dans la vraie vie
et où c'est mon médecin traitant c'est
un très bon médecin il est très bien une
suite depuis des années j'ai jamais une
arme à passer il faut il faut donner
aussi cette opinion là le royaume uni a
plutôt réussi sa campagne de vaccination
et le pilier s'est-elle astrazeneca
d'accord moi y'a pas de soucis je vous
dis moi ce que me dit mon médecin
traitant dans la vraie vie quand je moi
j'ai aucun problème à me faire vacciner
et 6e et donc je vais voir mon médecin
traitant et j'écoute bêtement ce qui me
dit voilà et jodie vous faites vacciner
ou pfizer ou au modern amepa l'astra
zelekha voilà et donc à écouter
que voulez vous après on peut on peut
s'étonner du fait que dans la population
en france on prenne pas pour argent
comptant tout ce que dit monsieur castex
où tout ce que dit monsieur véran en
même temps il ya un an d'expertisé
moi je vous dis franchement je leur
confierait pas mon peigne est par contre
quand mon médecin il me parle et bain et
j'ai tendance à écouter
donc moi je vais conseiller personnes
pour aller faire vacciner à l'astra
c'est les cas je vais est conseillé aux
gens d'aller se faire vacciner ça c'est
certain
et après à chacun verra dans ce que dans
l'opinion qui se fait avec le personnel
médical qu'il a autour de lui
voilà est juste une chose si vous me le
permettez par rapport à ce qu'a dit
alexis poulain juste avant je pense
qu'il ya là quelque chose d'essentiel
parce que la situation sanitaire c'est
important la situation sociale aussi et
quand il évoque notamment puisqu'on
parlait des commerces
madame borne à elle vient d'évoquer le
fait que sur le chômage partiel y allait
avoir une baisse de la prise en charge
par l'état et donc une hausse de la
prise en charge par les employeurs et
que la rémunération des salariés
allaient passer de 84 à 72 % donc bien
évidemment derrière on va avoir une
vague de licenciements désastreuse est
ce qu'à dit monsieur poulin sur la gs
c'est à dire la réforme de la gs est à
dire la réforme de la garantie des
salaires quand on a une entreprise en
liquidation judiciaire c'est extrêmement
important
ce gouvernement vient de 2,2
fragilisé totalement la garantie sur les
salaires au moment où on va avoir une
vague de licenciements et de pse et il
faut rappeler que au mois de janvier ce
gouvernement à réformer l'aide au
logement pour avec 700 millions d'euros
d'économies sur le dos des allocataires
au logement
voilà ce que fait ce gouvernement en
situation de pandémie il baisse les
aides qui protège contre la précarité et
ça c'est un véritable scandale
on va se retourner vers le président de
la confédération des commerçants francis
palombes vous vous partagez cette
crainte dit par benjamin à marla
garanties notamment sur les salaires la
fragilisation de tout à un pan de
l'économie
c'est évident que monsieur main même
raison de formuler des propos de grande
prudence et de grandes interrogations
c'est vrai que l'aspect social est quand
même très important
alors les entreprises que je porte ont
le nez dans le guidon concernant
également un aspect sur lequel je vais
me montrer très très très très vigilant
c'est les stocks
vous savez qu'une entreprise qui est
restée fermée il ya eu un petit problème
une entreprise une entreprise qui est
restée fermée pendant plusieurs mois
eh bien les stocks se sont accumulés les
factures arrivent et doivent-elles payer
donc il y à un élargissement des aides
de c'est vrai que vous me trouvez
peut-être ce soir très attaché et ne
sont pas les commerçants des mendiants
et des mendiants dead
nous voulons travailler servir nos
consommateurs faire revivre nos
centres-villes bien évidemment mais là
je suis un peu moi même vraiment sur le
sujet permanent au quotidien sur
l'attribution des de renforcer ça a été
le cas cet après midi dans les propos du
conseiller du ministre qui a participé
pendant 45 minutes à la rencontre et
nous avons apparemment je dis bien
attrayant parce qu'un prix il faut que
les faits se concrétise
nous avons été quand même entendu et
nous nous avons pu faire valoir des
aménagements et des renforcements dead
pour certaines typologies d'entreprises
ce qui n'était pas le cas
actuellement nous avons demandé
également des contrôles très sévères
on va nous en donner la preuve
d'afriscoop à des ministres concernant
des grandes surfaces qui n'ont pas
respecté les règles des produits non
essentiels et qui ont continué à les
vendre malgré que les magasins en centre
ville étaient fermés dont vous voyez
nous sommes dans une grande vigilance
nous devons collaborer avec l'état et
évidemment nous avons besoin days c'est
assurément mais il faut il faut être
présent et très très vigilant sur les
chiens est en train de se passer
merci francis palombes merci également à
benjamin marais alexis paulhan d'avoir
été avec nous pour ce décryptage suite à
cette je ne sais plus d'ailleurs énième
jeu jallet là comptez vous fait
l'heureuse énième conférence de presse
du jeudi merci à tous les trois restez
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons du sommet virtuel sur le
climat qui marque le retour des
etats-unis dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement
à l'initiative de joe biden qui met en
garde contre le coût de l'inaction et
puis nous reviendrons sur la suspension
des droits de la syrie elle a été votée
par les états membres de l'organisation
pour l'interdiction des armes chimiques
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans va te suicider ça
ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gaffes à ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom est en ligne quel
rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et
big for donc les gaffes à s'organiser
pour annuler quelqu'un sur internet sur
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux hanul à des entreprises
privées de prendre cette décision mais
ça doit être à la justice de prendre
cette décision
[Musique]
la crise du côté de 19 à semble-t-il
mise en lumière lippert mondialisation
et les contraintes qui vont avec
démondialiser pas sur un coup de
baguette magique ça coûte cher de
relocaliser il faut aussi changer ce
pourquoi les entreprises sont partis il
ya de grandes façon de le voir et qui
implique des stratégies qui sont
complètement différentes
vous pouvez essayer de refaire venir de
la vieille industrie qui a disparu ou
des secteurs qui ont disparu mais s'ils
ont disparu il ya une vieille a une
bonne raison
l'autre façon de voir c'est de savoir
quels sont les nouveaux secteurs
auxquels sont les secteurs l'avenir
qu'on peut arriver à conserver chez nous
si un jour on veut re localiser et bien
il faut déjà empêché les cerveaux de
partir ou en tous cas lors donner des
moyens pour qu'ils aient envie de rester
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
inventons soyez les bienvenus en direct
sur rt francs si vous nous rejoignez
premier jour du sommet virtuel sur le
climat organisée par les états unis
objectif renforcer la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique une thématique
consensuel qui a vu de nombreux chefs
d'état s'exprimaient dont joe biden
bladimir footing sous jean ping ou
encore emmanuel macron retour sur cette
première journée avec un thé au point
bas remettre les états unis au centre de
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
c'était l'un des enjeux de cette
première journée du sommet virtuel sur
le climat joe biden a invité plus de
quarante dirigeants mondiaux à
s'exprimer sur cette thématique qui fait
l'objet d'un rare consensus à l'échelle
internationale deuxième à s'exprimer
après sa vice-présidente kamala harris
le locataire de la maison blanche a tenu
à montrer la détermination de washington
en la matière les etats unis s'engagent
à réduire leurs émissions de gaz à effet
de serre de moitié d'ici la fin de cette
décennie
c'est ce que nous nous sommes fixés en
tant que nation
c'est ce que nous pouvons atteindre si
nous construisons une économie non
seulement prospère mais aussi plus
saines juste et propre pour le bien de
la planète
ces avancées vont permettre à l'amérique
d'arriver à une économie avec zéro
émission de co2 d'ici 2050 près de
quatre ans après l'annoncé par donald
trump du retrait américain de l'accord
de paris joe biden semble vouloir faire
du défi climatique un thème majeur de
son mandat une volonté d'accélérer la
lutte environnementale partagé par
emmanuel macron un seul objectif dans
les prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois
accélérer accélérer sur la mise en
oeuvre des engagements à l'horizon 2030
qui soit précis mesurables vérifiables
au fond 2030 et le nouveau 2050 c'est ce
plan que l'union européenne a mis sur la
table en décembre
traduite dans une loi climat européenne
avec le green deal pour lui donner corps
dans un climat géopolitique tendu
l'enjeu climatique semble réchauffer les
relations ont
occidentaux chinois et russes le
président chiche antique qui participait
pour la première fois un sommet
international avec joe biden et le
président russe vladimir poutine ont
également tenu à démontrer leur
engagement en la matière c'est ce cas là
c'est la fédération de russie souhaite
sincèrement intensifier la coopération
internationale afin de poursuivre la
recherche de solutions efficaces aux
problèmes du changement climatique comme
d'ailleurs à tous les autres problèmes
mondiaux aiguë robben l'onglet nous
continuerons à donner la priorité à la
préservation de l'environnement réel
suivre une voie de développement verte
et à faible émission de carbone
la chine s'efforcera d'atteindre le pic
des émissions de dioxyde de carbone
d'ici 2030 et de parvenir à la
neutralité carbone d'ici 2060 une
concorde internationale qui pourrait
pourtant avoir du mal à se conclure
autrement que par de simples
déclarations d'intention un motif
d'inquiétude pour la communauté
scientifique qui tient la semaine des
larmes et réclament des engagements plus
contraignant pour les états l'onu estime
que la température pourrait augmenter de
3 à 5 degrés d'ici la fin du 21e siècle
bien loin de l'objectif d'un point 5°
prônée par l'accord de paris et pour en
parler nous sommes avec yves contassot
président de la convention pour une
république écologiquement de génération
s bonsoir iphone
merci d'être avec nous alors normalement
on l'a entendue dans ce sujet lors de ce
sommet beaucoup de voeux pieux c'est le
voeu h c'est d'ailleurs le cas pardon à
chaque fois mais dans les faits pas
toujours appliqué cette fois ci doit-on
y croire écoutez on voudrait y croire
on aimerait y croire mais quand
j'entends ce que vous avez publié de
l'extrait de l'intervention deux
présidents de républiques emmanuel
macron et quand je regarde des actes je
me dis qu'il va être difficile d'y
croire
parce qu'il dit qu'il faut accélérer
mais je pense qu'ils se trompent de
pédaler qu'il a les deux pieds sur le
frein
la dernière démonstration c'est la loi
climat où il ne reprend pas les
propositions sans filtre comme il s'y
était engagé de la convention citoyenne
et non seulement il ne reprend pas tout
mais ce qu'il reprend il va moins loin
que ce qui était envisagé ou suggérés
donc qu'il a faux du début à la fin et
en réalité c'est le président de la
parole président du verbe président de
la communication et malheureusement les
actes ne sont pas là ils ne sont pas là
pour quelle raison il ya des obstacles
infranchissables compliqué en france
notamment
il ya plusieurs raisons d'abord il ya un
lobby extrêmement fort de gens qui n'ont
aucune envie que la transition
écologique se produise prenez le lobby
des pétroliers le lobby automobile
le lobby aussi une partie du lobby du
bâtiment n'a aucune envie ça change
leur objectif c'est profit comme
toujours et pas de vrai changement
et puis vous avez dans la classe
politique encore beaucoup d'hésitations
beaucoup d'hésitations et
malheureusement à gauche comme à droite
on a bien vu qu'avec les présidents
successifs depuis 20 ans il ya eu peu
d'avancé je peux prendre un exemple la
rénovation des bâtiments ça fait dix ans
qu'on en parle et que ça n'avance
quasiment pas on est très très en retard
sur les objectifs
or les solutions elles sont connues dans
quasiment tous les domaines ce qu'il
faut c'est de la bonne
politique est là la volonté n'est pas là
on n'est pas du tout avec des gens qui
prennent à bras le corps notre avenir
parce que c'est l'avenir de l'humanité
est quand même c'est pas l'avenir de la
planète elle vivra très bien sans les
êtres humains elle a vécu longtemps
ensemble sans nous et elle peut vivre
encore longtemps sans doute mais c'est
notre avenir de l'humanité gueydan jeu
et là il n'ya pas la volonté politique
c'est pour ça que nous prônons vraiment
une recomposition politique autour de
cette question de notre avenir de notre
capacité à survivre et à faire en sorte
que nos enfants petits enfants arrière
petits enfants puissent vivre dans un
climat acceptable au plan humain et pas
simplement avec quelques-uns qui
arrêtent qui essaieront mais qu'ils n'y
arriveront pas de s'en sortir au
détriment de tous les autres
alors ça c'est pour la france on est
malgré tout un petit pays
les yeux évidemment les on a les yeux
tournés vers les états unis la chine
là aussi beaucoup de voeux un changement
même à 360° des états unis réduction de
50 à 52 % d'ici 2030 pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2050 ce assez pour
joe biden si jean ping lui affirmé
vouloir atteindre la neutralité carbone
en 2060 ça ce sont quand même des faits
importants
on peut y croire là encore oui oui c'est
important qu'il y ait ces déclarations
surtout après la période de monsieur
trump qui n'y est complètement qu'il
puisse y avoir un dérèglement climatique
mais il ya encore beaucoup d'obstacles
parce que on le voit bien cette
révolution climatique doit s'accompagner
en même temps d'une réduction des
inégalités si on veut qu'elle soit
acceptée
on l'a vu avec la crise des gilets
jaunes on ne fait pas d'écologie sans
justice sociale sans approfondissement
de la démocratie c'est-à-dire
participation des citoyennes et des
citoyens et donc c'est ça l'enjeu de
l'écologie politique c'est ça la
république écologie et c'est pour ça que
nous nous disons que c'est bien que
monsieur weiden que monsieur poutine etc
en face des grandes déclarations mais il
faut passer aux actes il faut passer aux
actes
et quand on voit les conflits par
exemple sur le gaz
avec la russie sa volonté de développer
des infrastructures qui sont pas
tellement écolo quand on voit
malheureusement la poursuite de grands
projets encore en chine de barrage qui
serait totalement en contradiction avec
le maintien de la biodiversité
on se dit que il faudrait sortir de ses
contradictions et pas se dire qu'on n'y
arrivera demain et en même temps au
quotidien prendre des décisions
contraires gartenberg a mis son petit
grain de sel dans cette conférence comme
elle l'avait fait d'ailleurs la dernière
fois avec brio en tout cas on l'a
remarqué si j'ose dire
elle a accusé les dirigeants d'ignorer
le changement climatique
on en est là où vous êtes un peu exagéré
de la part de cette jeune fille je
trouve qu'elle a un très grand intérêt
de dire assez crûment ce que beaucoup de
gens pensent c'est à dire que je
n'aurais pas dit ignorer au sens mes
connaissances mais ignorée au sens de
une faible volonté de mettre en oeuvre
les solutions
encore une fois qu'ils sont connus au
plan de ce qu'il faut faire des moyens à
mettre en oeuvre
je vois comme ce bal des annonces des
sommes tout à fait que le sale mais
encore faut-il qu'elle soit réellement
utilisés et bien d'utiliser on peut dire
qu'en france malheureusement il ya
quasiment rien dans ce domaine on est
très très très loin d'avoir une verrine
véritable green deal comme dit monsieur
macron mais qui serait au service de la
transition écologique son green deal
c'est en fait un simple verdissement des
politiques actuelles néolibérale mais
s'il n'y a pas de véritable volonté de
changer les objectifs et la finalité
même de ce qu'on produit
merci yves contassot d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france
velimir poutine près recevoir son
homologue ukrainien à moscou interrogée
sur la proposition de rencontre de
volodymyr zelensky de président russe
s'est dit prêt à recevoir l recevoir non
pas à n'importe quel moment pour évoquer
leurs relations bilatérales
mardi le président ukrainien avait
appelé venir' cooking à le rencontrer
dans la zone de conflit avec les
séparatistes pro russes dans l'est de
l'ukraine
écoutez le président russe quant à la
proposition des autorités ukrainiennes
du président dans les plénières zelensky
je voudrais dire la chose suivante dit
ces derniers temps le gouvernement
ukrainien actuelle a pris aucune mesure
visant à détruire les relations russo
cela concerne directement plusieurs
problèmes des relations bilatérales
cela concerne son attitude envers
l'église orthodoxe russe est en fait sa
destruction ou bien une tentative de la
tête
cela concerne son attitude à l'égard de
la langue russe et les ukrainiens qui
parle russe et les russes qui habitent
[Musique]
chambres offre il y a eu de nombreuses
mesures visant à détruire nos relations
ce que nous pouvons bien sûr que
regretter
plus douteux si le président céline ce
qui veut commencer à restaurer ces
relations nous ne pouvons que nous en
féliciter
repro ce jeu tour la question qui se
pose qu'est-ce qu'on veut disputer lors
de cette rencontre
s'il s'agit du dombass dans ce cas là il
faut tout d'abord que les responsables
ukrainiens rencontre les responsables
des républiques populaires de donetsk et
de lougansk facebook
alors je prends ton est ensuite discuter
de ces problèmes avec des représentants
des pays tiers dont la russie c'est la
première chose qu'a touré la deuxième
chose pour ce sens il s'agit du
renforcement des relations bilatérales
mais qui deviennent nous l'accueillerons
à moscou à tout moment opportun pour lui
parce que vous nous mourir ou d'ovni et
la russie qui met fin à ces exercices
militaires en crimée le ministre russe
de la défense a annoncé dans la journée
les exercices menés selon moscou pour
faire face aux activités menaçantes de
l'otan dans la région
ils ont été perçus comme une escalade
par washington et ont hautement
préoccupée l'union européenne
la correspondance à moscou d'antoine
claireaux le ministre de la défense a
fait une annonce très importante alors
qu'il inspectait des troupes mobilisées
sur la péninsule de crimée se disant
satisfaits de leur capacité à défendre
le pays
sergueï choïgou a annoncé la fin des
exercices militaires qui se déroulait
dans l'ouest et le sud du pays c'est à
dire à proximité de la frontière
ukrainienne
il a donc demandé à ce que les soldats
réintègrent leurs casernes
au cours des exercices les militaires
ont fait preuve d'un haut niveau de
formation professionnelle les
groupements les détachements et les
unités militaires ont respecté les
normes de mise en condition
opérationnelle du
au degré de création d'un groupement de
tromper de force de bonne exécution des
missions d'entraînement et de combat
j'estime que les objectifs de
l'inspection inopinés sont pleinement
atteint les forces armées ont démontré
leur capacité à assurer une défense
fiable du pays
par conséquent j'ai décidé de mettre 100
opérations de vérification dans les
districts militaire sud et ouest
cela ne veut pas dire pour autant que la
russie ne gardera pas un oeil sur les
exercices militaires de l'otan des
manoeuvres qui se dérouleront à sa
frontière immédiate
il faut continuer à surveiller la
situation dans les zones des exercices
défendre europe et être prêts à réagir
immédiatement en cas d'évolution
défavorable en retirant ses troupes de
cette région sous haute tension depuis
plusieurs semaines la russie envoie un
signal fort elle fait savoir de façon
concrète qu'elle ne menace personne
comme cela avait été précédemment dit et
répété cependant en retour moscou compte
bien suivre de très près l'activité
militaire de l'otan littéralement sur le
pas de sa porte
une suspension qui fait réagir les états
mans de l'océan décidé de soustraire
tout droit de vote à la syrie damas
accusé en effet l'utilisation d'armes
chimiques en 2017 sur un village détenus
par des rebelles ce qu'elle réfute
sa représentante auprès de cette
instance basée à la haye a dénoncé une
décision catastrophique paris et londres
ont salué l'initiative
une question de crédibilité selon les
deux pays nous coûte son côté regrette
que l'organisation se transforme en
outil politique écouter aujourd'hui
c'est un jour sombre dans l'histoire de
l'eau y est assez il est regrettable que
d'organes technique
l'organisation se soient transformés à
un instrument politique pour traîner en
justice un état membre cette fois ci
c'est la syrie nous avons vu comment les
normes du droit international étaient
bafoués au profit de règles définies par
un certain groupe de pays et pour en
parler nous sommes avec michèle rameau
essayiste ancien ambassadeur de france
bonsoir michel
merci d'être avec nous alors une
décision symbolique mais une défaite
diplomatique de la série de ses alliés
ou une décision politique comme le dit
la russie je crois que c'est une
décision politique évidemment c'est
l'impasse elle dans une décision
politique
finalement on est devant une fuite en
avant des pays occidentaux
une fuite en avant dans le déni dans le
mensonge dans l'intoxication de la
fabrication des faits qui concerne pas
seulement d'ailleurs l'organisation pour
l'interdiction des armes chimiques et 10
concernent de toute la mouvance des
hauts revenus sienne anglais globalement
lucas soit au conseil de sécurité ou
ailleurs je crois que c'est désolant car
ce en dépit du domaine de la diplomatie
c'est du domaine de je ne sais pas quoi
de la donner la fantaisie
ça n'est plus du domaine de l'analyse
politique c'est du domaine de la
psychanalyse plutôt comme le disait
finalement il ya quelques années déjà un
agent des services de renseignement qui
est restée dans l'anonymat plus ou moins
mais qu ils avouaient qu'ils aient pour
lui demander si les états occidentaux ne
pourrait pas faire un tel ou tel geste
pour essayer d'améliorer ou bien de
rétablir des contacts avec la syrie ou
avec interac ce soit un mot moins
anormales dix ans il disait non nous ne
pouvons pas décidément parce que nous
sommes allés trop loin dans la voie du
mensonge de l'intoxication de l'ain fox
de l'intox et la manipulation pour
revenir en arrière et je crois que ça
c'est une illustration
à défaut de pouvoir faire autre chose eh
bien on sent donc on persiste dans
l'avant sa job c'est une voie sans issue
parce que bien évidemment le disons
privait la syrie de ses droits à loyat c
est de son droit de vote et de ses
participations je crois que c'est un peu
illusoire
il ya belle lurette que la syrie ne
comptent plus là dessus ne continuent
sur leur lancée pour assurer dirait la
légalité internationale nous il ya s'est
distingué jusqu'à présent justement par
le traficotage des ddd des procédures
par l'al comment je dirais la tromperie
dans les moyens
les dans les dents dans les enquêtes
toutes les irrégularités qui avaient
fait l'objet d'ailleurs de de la la
pétition qui était qu'elle était lancée
la lettre de préoccupation qui avait été
lancée par l'ancien premier directeur
général de l'ul aux requêtes des 55
contre les airs la diffusion des armes
chimiques
l'ambassadeur josé boustany et qui
appelait ainsi niés par de grandes
personnalités notamment américaines et
qui appeler finalement le lot il ya
c'est à le revoir c'est un peu de
s'inquiéter nizon de la façon dont ces
procédures sont systématiquement trafic
est détournée par un certain nombre
groupes de pays
disons qu'ils sont en gros les pays
occidentaux pour parler clair je crois
que c'est ça le problème
en tout cas sa filiale et est accusée on
le sait michel rambo d'avoir utilisé du
sahara éclore lors des attaques heures
en mars 2010 est sur le village de
lattes et menez est ce que ce n'est pas
surtout le manque de réponses aux
interrogations de nos essais qui est
sanctionné non je crois que c'est le
traficotage des exemples est et des
procédures internes à l'eau il ya ces
suppressions des trois pays occidentaux
n'hésitez pas ne pas les nommer les
états unis la grande bretagne et la
france
biden qui a fait basculer les choses
justement je ne crois pas disons suite
on ne s'arrêtait pas beaucoup plus
glorieux
néanmoins je pense que la solidarité
occidentale s'est montré plus vigoureuse
depuis que ben hayden est revenu parce
que uni'sons un petit peu moins
polémique est intimement imprévisible
que donald trump pour sur le fond ce
n'est pas plus glorieux
joe by donne quand même un passif
c'est pas un passé politique seulement
il un passif politique notamment en ce
qui concerne les pays du grand
moyen-orient
tout l'été les pays arabes les pays
arabo musulmans c'est à dire de les
opérations démocrates soit disant
démocratisation en fait sont des
opérations de destruction de
déstabilisation pour la plus grande
gloire d'israël je crois que c'est ça
qui est inquiétant qui demande qui est
en jeu actuellement la plus loyale
revient en arrière quand on a trop menti
quand on l comment voulez vous que des
états qui se disent la fleur du
l'humanité puisse revenir en arrière et
dire on s'est trompé et bêtise et nous
c'est pas possible
et donc c'est désolant pour
internationale n'y a plus de droit
international et c'est ça le problème en
plus je dirais gars qui a une guerre qu
il ya une conjoncture actuelle qui est
marquée notamment par le soi-disant
dixième anniversaire de la dea début des
événements en syrie de la guerre de
syrie donc on fait tout pour persévérer
dans la même foi puisque on ne peut plus
revenir en arrière parce qu'on était
trop loin dans le mensonge est donc et
puis à la perspective des élections
présidentielles en syrie qui sont
décrétés davance illégale illégitime etc
etc
rappelons le une fois pour toutes
finalement il n'appartient ni à
l'amérique ni à la france vous reparler
de ces légers ces élections
pardonnez-moi en série 1
on parle aussi de reconstruction de la
syrie damas ce qu'annonce la tenue d'un
scrutin présidentiel le 26 mai ça veut
dire que louis gassée voit la marque un
petit peu ça parte à cet instant-là
précis stratégique pour le pays
je crois que c'est pas là où il ya ce
qui est en jeu c'est la faction de la
façon de fonctionner de loyat c'est josé
boustany leucate est le premier
directeur général de l'oic ac avait une
opinion qui étaient affaiblies vers ce
jeu neutre et que la lettre qui a été
adressée à l'actuel directeur de l'ot
yaté finalement lui demander de revoir
les procédures et s'inquiétait des
pressions et du détournement des
procédures
disons par les trois pays occidentaux la
grande bretagne la france et les états
unis bien évidemment alors je crois il
faut pas oublier que des dp qui n'hésite
pas la menace conflit personnel je
rappellerai que john bolton le
schtroumpf grognon de l'équipe
précédente finalement dix ans avait
menacé josé boustany à l'époque de la
guerre d'irak
hubble dans son dans son avis la vienne
à 100 sa famille en disant nous savons
sont vos enfants ce qui est indigne du
représentant d'une grande puissance
je crois que l'eau il ya c'est de voter
la suspension salle suspendra pas grand
chose pas beaucoup de droits de vote de
la syrie parce que la syrie appelle
lurette qu'elle n'attend plus rien du
tout le jass et sinon des condamnations
puisque sa pompe tonne et bâtons là elle
n'attend plus rien de l'occident ni la
communauté internationale parce que
c'est de cette façon que ça fonctionne
je noterai que tout ce qui est pris les
décisions de l'homme de la communauté
internationale actuellement telle
qu'elle est à l'occidentale s'est
dirigée par les trois membres permanents
occidentaux du conseil de sécurité et
bien z ça aboutit à détruire faut rayer
la syrie de la carte
c'est un politicien et un ethnocide
comme on dirait peut-être pas un
génocide
enfin quoi coach des mesures génocidaire
qui sont prises la citation de la syrie
et tragique du peuple syrien et de
l'état série et on cherche à éradiquer
et enrayer la série de la carte je pense
que la décision de l'eau il ya ces
quêtes une décision soucieux sous forte
pression des trois beaux grands pays
occidentaux qui se croient à la fleur de
la communauté internationale eh bien je
crois que ça ne fait que confirmer cet
état
c'est désolant du point de vue du droit
international je pense qu'il n'y a plus
de diplomates si possible il n'y a plus
de raisonnement possible on dirait il en
six sociétés est folle ohé
que emballé il s'agissit remettre de
l'ordre qui peut l'être merci michel
raimbault d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france et dans le reste de
l'actualité l'australie qu'annuler hier
un accord passé avec la chine dans le
cadre du projet de nouvelle route de la
soie le chef de la diplomatie le juge
incompatible avec la politique étrangère
de l'australie est contraire à ses
relations extérieures pékin fut si jude
mesures déraisonnables et provocatrice
les relations bilatérales ont commencé à
se détériorer en 2018 lorsque canberra
exclu le géant chinois des télécoms
huawai de la construction de son réseau
singer elles se sont encore tendues
lorsque le premier ministre australien a
rappelé l'an dernier à une enquête
internationale sur les origines de la
pandémie
le gouvernement fédéral australien de
façon déraisonnable a opposé son veto à
cet accord de coopération signé par le
gouvernement de victoria et la chine
interfèrent imprudemment et perturbe la
coopération et les échanges normaux des
deux parties cela porte gravement
atteinte aux relations sino
australiennes et à la confiance mutuelle
entre les deux pays
la chine exprime son vif mécontentement
et sa ferme opposition à cette situation
et a déjà entrepris des démarches sévère
auprès de l'australie la partie chinoise
se réserve le droit de prendre des
mesures complémentaires à cet égard nous
exhortons l'australie d'abandonner la
mentalité de la guerre froide et les
préjugés idéologiques de considérer la
coopération sino-australienne de manière
objective et rationnelle de corriger
immédiatement ses erreurs de tourner la
page de cesser de s'engager sur la
mauvaise voie et d'aggraver les
relations déjà difficiles entre la chine
et l'australie
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la conférence de
presse sur la situation sanitaire jean
castex a prévenu d'emblée le niveau de
circulation se réduit mais reste très
élevé nous devons rester lucides et
poursuivre nos efforts et puis nous
parlerons de la facture de
cette pièce ducobu pour les finances
publiques jusqu'en 2020 de à l'objet de
l'édito de jacques sapir
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous ces
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui compte l on soit vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on est une gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande île interview tous les
jours des groupes de pression remettent
en cause notre pays au niveau de son
histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au présent
pour eux la souveraineté nationale ou
populaire est inacceptable car assimilés
aux régimes dictatoriaux ou à une vision
dépassée de l'intérêt national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage à abandonner l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une europe
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxe protectionniste ou en mettant
en place des lois dissymétrique la
mondialisation se révèle un piège pour
tous les autres il faut avoir le courage
de faire le constat que l'europe à 27
noeuds permet de réaliser le vrai
consensus que sur des sujets mineurs ou
à la mode
[Musique]
ce sont les trafiquants de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adeptes de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage
montagnes de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose l'argent
sale devient très rapidement et très
facilement gris et puis blanc il suffit
de passer par quelques sociétés écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dire nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
ça
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de nero
et gagarine était présent à chaque au
point de bâtiments de salles de sport de
place de la cité des étoiles moi je
crois beaucoup dans la diplomatie
scientifique et quand vous parlez de la
coopération scientifique sur la station
mir ou la station spatiale
internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
oh
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience de concerts symphoniques qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa par an
pathamathan vous avez envie de faire ça
il faut que leur qu'istres groove la
musique c'est la traduction la plus
poétique de la vie si vous mettez pas la
vie des évidemment on s'embête il faut
sortir les notes de leurs univers
carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qu'il ya entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
il est 21h soyez les bienvenus en direct
sur rt france bienvenue dans cette
deuxième partie d'émission
et voici les titres le pic de la
troisième vague semble derrière nous
mais jean castex a prévenu d'emblée le
niveau de circulation se réduit mais
reste très élevé si le couvre feu est
maintenu au moins jusqu'à la mi mai la
rentrée se fera bien le 26 avril pour
les maternelles et les élémentaires avec
le déploiement de tests salivaires mais
aussi des autotests pour les personnels
de l'éducation nationale puis et lycéens
olivier ferrand lui tente de rassurer
sur la vaccination astrazeneca 424
milliards d'euros c'est la facture
astronomique de la crise du coc vide
pour les finances publiques jusqu'en
2022 qui a tiré exactement dans ce
chiffre fourni par le gouvernement
corresponde vraiment la réalité pourquoi
cette somme nous était l'annoncer
maintenant autant de questions
auxquelles jacques sapir tentera de
répondre tout à l'heure dans son édito
une décision stupéfiante voire
scandaleuse pour beaucoup celle de la
cour de cassation de jauge et
irresponsable pénalement le meurtrier de
sarah halimi sexagénaire juifs tués en
2010 est à paris une affaire qui relance
le débat sur la responsabilité pénale
des personnes atteintes de troubles
psychiatriques sur fond de consommation
de drogue
emmanuel macron on veut un changement de
loi la soeur de la victime va elle porté
plainte en israël pour tenter d'obtenir
un procès
mais bon
un conférence de presse de jean castex
en fin d'après midi donc sur la
situation sanitaire le pic de la
troisième vague semble derrière nous
mais le premier ministre a prévenu si le
niveau de circulation se réduit il reste
très élevé le couvre feu reste maintenue
au moins jusqu'à la mi mai les
précisions de david khalifa une
visibilité est finalement presque
identique qu'avant ce traditionnel point
presse hebdomadaire jean castex a
d'abord confirmé la réouverture des
écoles ce lundi concernant lé crèches
maternelles et primaires un dépistage
massif va être mise en place avec
notamment le déploiement des autotests
et tests salivaires dans tous les
établissements scolaires du territoire
un choix assumé par l'exécutif est une
fierté d'avoir répondu aux objectifs
affichés et concernant l éducation
nationale les écoles vous l'aurez
compris largement abordés durant ce
point presse mais les français
espéraient y voir plus clair pour le
retour à la vie normale
et ça reste encore une fois est très
floue ans même si la situation sanitaire
s'améliore le premier ministre s'est
montré prudent et n'a rien dévoilé au
presque à du calendrier du déconfinement
néanmoins l'exécutif promet de lever les
restrictions aux déplacements le 3 mai
prochain
pour ce qui est du couvre feu en
revanche le gouvernement a confirmé que
celui-ci restera quoi qu'il arrive en
vigueur jusqu'à la mi-mai pour la
réouverture des terrasses des bars et
restaurants de sel est des lieux
culturels
l échéance à la mi mai a été confirmé
écoutez le premier ministre à partir du
3 mai également
nous pourrons lever les contraintes de
déplacement en journée est envisagée
sous réserve de l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire
un nouveau train de réouverture autour
de la mi mai qui pourrait commencer par
les commerces certaines activités
culturelles et sportives et les
terrasses cette liste n'est pas
définitivement fixée
elle sera assortie de conditions
particulières le cas échéant je le
disais territorialisée qui évolueront au
fil des étapes
autre point abordé la campagne de
vaccination avec encore une fois une
défense sont relâche d'astrazeneca tous
les membres du gouvernement présents
ce soir on prononçait le nom du vaccin
jean castex a d'abord rappelé que
l'exécutif rattraper son retard dans le
calendrier vaccinal initial elle a aussi
une certaine forme d'autosatisfaction
l'objectif vacciner 20 millions de
français à la mi mai et 30 millions à la
mi juin est toujours d'actualité
et pour cela il faut convaincre les
français qu'astrazeneca est sans danger
le chef du gouvernement a donc tenté de
redonner du crédit aux vaccins
britannique au suédois pointé du doigt
pour ses effets indésirables et
notamment quelques cas de thrombose
olivier ferrand a pour seul a tenté de
nuancer en utilisant à des comparatifs
de la vie quotidienne écouter ministre
de la santé dans de très rares cas il
peut provoquer des thromboses c'est à
dire la formation de petits cailloux qui
peuvent aller bouchée des haines qui
peuvent aller boucher la circulation
veineuse et provoquer pour le coup des
effets indésirables plus graves mais ils
sont très rares c'est cinq cas environ
pour un million de personnes vaccinées
je vous donnais une comparaison si vous
prenez l'avion pour traverser
l'atlantique
vous avez un risque également de faire
des thromboses parce que vous allez être
moins mobiles et ce risque
si vous traversez l'atlantique en avion
il est 50 fois plus élevé que si vous
faites d'actionner par astra zeneca ça
permet quand même je crois de
relativiser les choses
minimiser les risques encourus pour
convaincre un maximum de français de se
faire vacciner avec astrazeneca c'était
l'objectif affiché est annoncée de ce
soir hormis ça vous l'aurez compris il
faudra patienter jusqu'à la prise de
parole des manuels macron pour avoir un
calendrier plus net plus claire du ad
confinement lorsque le temps des bonnes
nouvelles viendra astrazeneca le vaccin
est dans le viseur de l'union européenne
elle s'apprête à lancer une action en
justice contre le laboratoire sud et au
britannique lui reprochant de ne pas
avoir honoré son contrat de livraison
des doses astrazeneca toujours qui
suscitent la défiance en france le
gouvernement
on l'a entendu tout à l'heure a tenté de
convaincre de recourir à ce sérum
indispensable pour tenir l'objectif de
millions de personnes ayant reçu au
moins une dose de d'abîmer un reportage
signé dimitri sociaux mi-mars jean
castex a reçu une première dose
d'astrazeneca face aux caméras mais cela
n'a pas suffi beaucoup de français
restent réticents à ce vaccin
dimanche dernier à la sortie de ce
centre parisien réservé aux personnels
prioritaires de plus de 55 ans les
volontaires étaient bien peu nombreux ça
ne pose pas de problème j'ai bien été
informé par le médecin du centre sur les
risques un film
de thrombose lilac six nations
astrazeneca mais bon j'ai préféré me
faire vacciner dans et déjà et donc je
n'avais pas le choix du médecin je
l'accepté sans problème il y a plus de
gens pour vous accueillir que deux
patients c'est à dire que il ya très peu
du monde
je suis même étonnée qu'on ait aussi peu
à nice un centre qui devaient rester
ouverts tout le week-end à fermer faute
de candidats dès samedi midi
lui aussi ne proposait que l'astra
zeneca nous avons eu seulement 58
personnes qui se sont présentés le matin
pour quatre mille doses de vaccins
disponibles
la suspension pour quelques jours du
vaccin en france au mois de mars est
encore dans les mémoires
la faute à quelques rares cas de
thrombose chez certaines personnes
plutôt jeunes dans les jours suivant la
vaccination depuis sa nouvelle
autorisation mi mars le gouvernement a
décidé de réserver l'astra zeneca ou
plus de 55 ans à ce jour l'agencé
nationale de sécurité du médicament ne
dénombre que huit décès pour 2 millions
700 mille doses d'astrazeneca injecté en
france ce jeudi
olivier véran dans sa conférence de
presse hebdomadaire dédiée au virus a
voulu consacrer sa première réponse à la
défiance subie par le vaccin à seize
années car c'est un vaccin à l'action on
ne peut plus classique en matière de
vaccination en cours depuis des
décennies dans plein de maladies comme
d'autres vaccins comme la plupart des
vaccins plus comme beaucoup de
médicaments d'ailleurs il peut donner ce
qu'on appelle des effets indésirables
passagers sans gravité dans de très
rares cas il peut provoquer des
thromboses c'est à dire la formation de
petit caillou qui peuvent aller bouchée
des haines qui peuvent déboucher la
circulation veineuse et provoquer pour
le coup des effets indésirables plus
graves mais ils sont très rares face à
la circonspection des français le
gouvernement envisage un grand plan de
communication des personnalités du monde
de la culture seraient sollicités selon
le canard enchaîné le premier ministre
aimerait même que la chanteuse sheila se
fassent vacciner devant les caméras
quoi qu'il en soit aucun vaccin ne sera
perdu la france prévoit de faire don de
sang mindo d'astrazeneca à des pays en
développement d'ici la fin du mois
mais pour parler de ce fameux vaccin
strazeele et cas nous sommes en direct
depuis et ses terres avec bharat bank
kenya expert en maladies infectieuses à
l'université d'exeter c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
bonsoir baraton kenya merci d'être avec
nous quand vous voyez c'est son entrain
à nice et un ville française
complètement vide 1 58 personnes pour
4000 dos en tant que britannique un
vivement au royaume-uni qu'est ce que
vous vous dites que je suis très
attristé d'entendre cela le vaccin
astrazeneca oxford est sûre il vous
protégera il vous sauvera la vie et il
est très décevant d'entendre que les
français ne veulent pas apprendre le
vaccin astrazeneca
je demanderai au gouvernement français
de renforcer ses efforts afin je le
communiqué d'enseignés de rassurer le
peuple français ce vaccin leur sauvera
la vie et changera il faut changer la
façon dont sont propagées formation sur
le vaccin
il n'est pas dangereux quand certains
cas très rare il ya des liens entre eux
des caillots sanguins et le vaccin mais
c'est une chance sur un million
comment s'y est pris nos gouvernements
chez vous parce qu'il ya eu des soucis
d'ailleurs c'est parti dans les cas de
thrombose au royaume uni il a d'ailleurs
été arrêtés on en reparlera après puis
déconseillé aux moins de 30 ans c e soir
grâce ou à cause du gouvernement
français grâce au gouvernement
britannique ou alors plutôt les
britanniques sont tout simplement
peut-être moins sceptique envers la
vaccination
nous avons le même problème nous formons
une grande famille ce qui arrive en
france arrive également dans les autres
régions
est ce que nous faisons unis ça ne se
répétant des messages mesure est
raisonnable c'est caillots sanguins sont
très rares et d'autre part si le
contracte la au vide 19 alors cela peut
également se moquera beaumontoise et
l'apparition de quel sanguins les
fumeurs les personnes qui reçoivent de
long de contraception les personnes qui
prennent l'avion ont tous un risque pour
nantes est plus élevé 2 qu'elle s'en
gardent donc si l'on compare ce vaccin
avec d'autres causes telles orientations
de la fréquence de caillots sanguins
le vaccin est plus sûr et sauve la vie
face à la cofidis n'a fui parce qu'on
rappelle une évidence peut-être pour
vous mais la phrase est née cas c'est le
pilier de la vaccination au royaume uni
ils disent non c'est ainsi que kaiser où
nous avons distribué plusieurs millions
de 12 ouvriers ils sommes très prudents
avec tous nos vaccins mais comme je les
ai déjà dit ce qui est important c'est
que le gouvernement français a encouragé
ses citoyens à prendre
ce vaccin est une peine mesures contre
le temps d'y penser il faut donc s'y
faire vacciner aussi rapidement que
possible
il est néanmoins réservé aux plus de 55
ans en france est déconseillé aux moins
de 30 ans au royaume uni est ce que cela
a du sens pour vous le royaume uni a
adopté un principe de précaution
le nombre de cas de problème de
thrombose on expliquer très rare sur
vienne
chez les personnes plus jeunes donc afin
d'être prudent et même jusqu'à l'extrême
l'ue a décidé que les personnes de moins
de 30 ans recevrait d'autres plateformes
de vaccins c'est à dire des vaccins du
type taser au moderna et que les
personnes plus âgées de plus de 50
depuis de 30 ans recevrait les autres
vaccins mais également le vaccin
astrazeneca une bonne communication des
informations scène c'est très important
en gagnant on a vu ces images on va
certainement d'ailleurs les revoir dans
quelques instants d'une angleterre
libéré johnson d'ailleurs tous fiers
qu'il tend une bière dans le centre du
pays
ça veut dire quoi qu'il n'y a quasiment
plus de mort du co vide au royaume uni
quelle est la situation la maladie et
les décès dus à la qualité existent
encore envoyé cette nuit c'est
malheureux pour moi cette nuit dans un
espace fermé peu ventilée avec d'autres
gens c'est très risqué pour ederson le
premier ministre est un homme politique
et non pas un scientifique a donc autre
message tout comme celui d'emmanuel mc
ren et que la situation va s'améliorer
moi en tant que scientifique je vous
répète d'être prudent de faire attention
de ne pas encourager les gens à se
rassembler en intérieur dans des lieux
peu ventilée car c'est là que la
contamination se fait et bien sûr
lorsqu'on a bu de l'alcool
la gare de baisse et on peut douter que
commencer à prendre les gens non ses
bras chanter ensemble
embrasser les gens ce sont les
comportements risqués donc il ne faut
pas encourager les gens à boire tout moi
à boire dehors et à ne pas baisser la
garde alors tant que scientifique
justement est ce que vous vous méfier
grandement
et variant alors le marié en anglais là
vous y êtes habitués évidemment mais on
parle surtout aujourd'hui du variant
indien par exemple même si les
frontières sont fermées hier ce que
c'est quelque chose qui vous inquiète
les variants neutre avec quelle que soit
leur origine
car certains de ces variants pourrait
être plus contaminateur pourrait même à
contourner les anticorps développé par
le vaccin pourrait également être plus
infectieux nous le ferions bien sûr
avoir de la chance et ne trouvait avec
des variants away we go mois dangereux
qui deviennent dominant mais nous devons
faire attention aussi invariants plus
dangereux à part et qui est plus
contaminant qui est plus virulent qui
contourne le vaccin alors il faut
essayer de le contrôler une façon de le
faire du yo-yo puni c'est que l'union
européenne et le royaume uni et les
etats unis devraient se rassembler avec
lone s'étire devant interrompre le
système des brevets temporairement et
permettent ainsi de distribuer le vaccin
est de produire les vaccins dans le
monde entier très rapidement afin dé
contribuer rapidement c'est une urgence
mondiale en appel aux dirigeants de
l'union européenne du royaume uni et des
êtres deux hommes se tourner vers les
compagnies pharmaceutiques et de leur
demander d'interrompre de mettre en
pause en suspense et ses brevets merci
beaucoup a rapidement gagné d'avoir été
avec nous en direct du royaume uni ce
soir
424 milliards d'euros c'est la facture
astronomique de la crise du coc vite
pour les finances publiques françaises
jusqu'en 2022 un chiffrage a donné par
olivier dussopt le ministre des comptes
publics alors même que l'épidémie
continue de sévir
qu'y a t'il exactement dans ces 4 124
milliards qu en est il vraiment la
réalité pourquoi cette somme nous est
annoncé maintenant c'est l'objet de
l'édito échos ce soir de jacques sapir
alors bon soir jacques faut-il penser de
ceux ci fera je pense que c'est vrai que
chiffrage j'ai du mal à le dire même 424
milliards d'euros ça fait peur oui
bonsoir c'est fanny oui effectivement
c'est une somme qui a été annoncé par le
ministre des comptes publics monsieur
olivier dussopt et alors c'est une somme
qui est censé couvrir à la fois l'année
2020 l'année 2000 21 et l'année 2022
alors évidemment on peut être sûr de
2020 puisque les comptes ont été arrêtés
évidemment on est en train de dépenser
cet argent 2022 on n'y est pas encore
donc on voit qu'il ya évidemment des des
choses qui sont sur des choses qui le
sont beaucoup moins
dans ce chiffrage après on peut penser
aussi que en faisant ce chiffrage
le ministre des comptes publics fait
plus de la politique que de la
comptabilité
alors jacques 1-2 quoi est-on sûr
actuellement
alors on a d'abord ceux qui étaient
dépensés l'année dernier en 2020 pour ça
on connaît les sommes c'est à peu près
158 milliards de ça on est absolument
sûr après il y à ce qui est prévu de
dépenser pour l'année qui vient pas pour
l'année dans lequel nous sommes donc 171
milliards et là il ya déjà des petits
problèmes parce que évidemment cette
somme elle inclut quoi elle inclut le
chômage partiel
elle inclut le fonds de solidarité et
inclut aussi le plan de relance sauf que
eh ben il ya de grandes incertitudes que
ce soit sur plan de relance sur le
chômage partiel voire même sur le plan
de solidarité et donc tout ça évidemment
ce n'est pas très très très sûr en tous
les cas pour 2021 alors pas très sûr
pour quelles raisons eh bien il ya
plusieurs raisons
première raison évidemment la question
dépêchez vous souvenez il et les prêts
garantis par l'état
on ne sait pas en réalité si les
entreprises pourront effectivement les
rembourser ça va courir sur 2021 sur
2022 est donc évidemment si elles ne
peuvent pas les rembourser
il faudra immédiatement que l'état se
substitue à elle est donc ça fera des
sommes en plus deuxième point le plan de
relance alors dans le plan de relance
d'abord il ya une partie des 100
milliards qui ne sont pas de l'argent
dépensé qui sont tout simplement des
déductions fiscales
est-ce que ça a été inclus dans la somme
ou pas c'est d'abord une question qu'on
peut se poser
et puis il ya des sommes qui étaient
déjà prévus par exemple dans le secteur
de la santé que l'on a rajouté dans le
plan de relance est ce qu on a continué
à les compter deux fois dans le budget
bon là aussi il ya de très grands
l'incertitude sur l'ensemble des sommes
qui seraient dépensées dans cette année
elle a nommé jacques comment fait le
gouvernement pour arriver à ce total de
424 milliards c'est assez facile si vous
voulez ce que fait le gouvernement
il prend les 158 milliards qui ont été
dépensés l'année dernière il rajoute les
171 milliards qu'il a prévu de dépenser
et qu'il est d'ailleurs effectivement
entrés en partie de dépenser cette année
et il y ajoute 95 milliards pour 2022 et
là c'est 95 milliards honnêtement on ne
sait pas ce qu'il en sera ça peut être
moins dans certains cas par exemple
admettons que l'épidémie soit
complètement contrôlé à cet automne et à
mon avis les dépenses seront nettement
moins importants comme ça peut être
nettement plus si on a une épidémie qui
court jusqu'à la fin de l'année
et si on a un des gros problèmes
d'insolvabilité au niveau des
entreprises qui ont pris ce qu'on
appelle des prêts garantis par l'état
des pg e ce qui obligerait comme je les
dis l'état à se substituer à elle alors
justement quelles sont ces
z'ont politique alors les raisons
politiques il y a si vous voulez dans
cet effet d'annonce parce qu'on on voit
bien ce qu'a fait olivier dussopt ben ça
ça enlève de l'effet d'annoncé à mon
avis elles sont deux la première raison
à l'écouté que c'est une évidence
emmanuel macron est d'ores et déjà en
campagne pour sa réélection en 2022
c'est tout à fait clair et de ce point
de vue là eh bien je pense qu'il faut
apprécier ce montant de 4 124 milliards
dans le cadre des annonces qui seront
faites dans le cadre de la campagne
électorale ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est que on se rappel
l'année dernière
emmanuel macron avait annoncé en mars
2020 qu'il ferait tout ce qu'il faut
pour soutenir les français et soutenir
l'activité économique
quoi qu'il en coûte et bien que c'est
une manière de montrer justement que ce
quoi qu'il en coûte
eh bien il a été poussé jusqu'au bout et
qu'on a vraiment mis de l'argent pour
soutenir l'activité
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait évident
mais vous sur ce point vous avez des
doutes
oui effectivement effectivement si vous
n'êtes quand on regarde les sommes qui
ont été dépensées au simple niveau du
gouvernement c'était au niveau
budgétaire
et bien qu est-ce qu on constate on
constate que la france oui bien sûr
elles à la dépense et on le voit la plus
dépensé que la moyenne de l'union
européenne mais elle a nettement moins
dépensé que l'allemagne que l'autriche
et surtout que le royaume uni ou que les
états unis et je signale que la les
sommes qui sont indiqués pour les états
unis ce sont des données du fonds
monétaire international elle n'inclut
pas le plan qui sera prévu qui sera en
fait voté au mois de juillet et qui
devrait rajouter 2200 milliards de
dollars à la facture donc on voit bien
là aussi qu' il ya un très gros
déséquilibre entre ceux qui étaient
dépensés en france et ce qui était
dépensé dans un certain des autres pays
on sait bien jacques aussi qu' il n'y a
pas que des dépenses budgétaires l'état
aussi garanti de nombreux prêts oui vous
avez tout à fait raison
stéphanie c'est tout à fait exact c'est
par exemple le cas des prêts garantis
aux entreprises c'est le cas des péchés
mais là encore si on fait la somme si on
additionne aux dépenses budgétaires les
mesures monétaires c'est-à-dire l'argent
qui est prêté ou ou qui est en garanties
de prêts par l'état alors on voit que la
situation de la france montrent un peu
surtout par rapport à la moyenne de
l'union européenne mais qu' elle ne
monte pas tant que ça par rapport à
l'allemagne par rapport à l'italie aussi
qui en a fait beaucoup plus que nous par
rapport au royaume uni et probablement
par rapport aux états unis si on y
inclut la l'ensemble des dépenses qui
ont été annoncés alors qu'il s'agisse du
plan byden de soutien à l'économie du
mois de mars dernier
ou qu'il s'agisse du futur plan de
relance qui sera voté donc cet été en
conclusion que faut-il penser donc de ce
chiffre de 4 124 milliards d'euros si
vous voulez la déclaration du ministre
elle est intéressante elle est
intéressante pour 3 pour trois choses
alors la première chose c'est évidemment
on voit bien que pour arriver à cette
somme est bien il a dû faire ce qu'on
appelle un petit peu enfin additionner
des pommes des poires et des oranges
c'est dire additionner des choses qui ne
sont pas exactement au même niveau
il ya déjà des sommes qui sont sûres et
puis à des sommes qui ne sont pas du
tout sûr donc ça ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est qu'on est
clairement en présence d'une déclaration
politique et il faut le comprendre
alors je n'en fais pas critiques au
ministre mais simplement il ne faut pas
non plus en être complètement du il
s'agit du type de déclaration que l'on a
dans toutes les campagnes électorales
avec ce qu'elles peuvent contenir
d'outrance ou d'arrangements avec la
vérité ça c'est le deuxième point le
troisième point il s'est peut-être plus
là dessus qu'il faudrait s'intéresser
c'est que évidemment ça nous invite à
remettre la situation de la france en
admettant même que voilà qu'on dépense
effectivement ces 4 124 milliards 4 124
milliards ça représenterait à peu
après 16 à 17% du pin kung dépensé 4 124
milliards dans les trois années donc
donc de 2020 à 2022 mais combien auront
dépensé les autres pays dans la même
période
et là on verra où on verrait en tous les
cas si on regardait un petit peu les
chiffres que la france certes on a fait
plus que ce qu'on a fait dans certains
autres pays
par exemple les pays d'europe centrale
ont beaucoup moins aidé leurs économies
parce qu'ils n'en ont pas les moyens
mais on en a fait moins que ce qui a été
fait en allemagne en italie et surtout
ce qui est très important ce qui est
fait hors de la zone euro en particulier
en grande-bretagne et aux etats-unis et
donc je crois que c'est ça la leçon
qu'il faut tirer de cette annonce de
chiffres par monsieur olivier dussopt
merci jacques import cette analyse et à
la semaine prochaine
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous revenons sur l' affaire halimi et
la décision de la cour de cassation de
jugé irresponsable pénalement le
meurtrier de cette sexagénaire juive une
affaire qui relance le débat sur la
responsabilité pénale des personnes
atteintes de troubles psychiatriques
[Musique]
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience de concerts symphoniques qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa par an
pathamathan vous avez envie de faire ça
l'est il faut que leur qu'istres groove
la musique c'est la traduction la plus
poétique de la vie si vous mettez pas la
vie des évidemment on s'embête il faut
sortir les notes de leurs univers
carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qu'il ya entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk heures nous
sommes au bord de la volga le plus long
fleuve d'europe
nous sommes chez boxart y allons faire
connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à ba là on est
alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois celle en profiter
en 2011 le monde manque pas un petit peu
non ah oui et c'est tous les fromages
tous les soucis sont toutes les les
croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
les français ne le savent pas je ne
pensais jamais de ma vie faire la plonge
et autonomie vous pouvez me souhaiter
bon courage
à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]
louis saillant est un mec ce commando
marine
il nous emmène dans les coulisses de la
guerre contre le djihadisme au sahel
l'ennemi la barre est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de jay liste on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême c'est vrai que c'est un terreau
qui peut favoriser l'extension du
terrorisme ne faut pas imaginer qu'il
suffit simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre
pour que l'islam c'est un guillaume a
qui sont embrigadés ils ont été séduits
ils ont été manipulés et d'autres qui
agissent de manière parfaitement
consciente et lucide je respecterai
toujours l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega liste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt francs si vous nous rejoignez la
sphère sarah limite c'était en 2017 à
paris la justice française à juger le 14
avril dernier irresponsable pénalement
le meurtrier de cette sexagénaire juive
de l'absence de procès pour ce violent
meurtre suscite depuis une vive émotion
retour en images sur cette affaire
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et face à cette décision de justice que
beaucoup trouvent choquante la soeur de
sarah halimi compte porter plainte en
israël pour tenter d'obtenir un procès
contre son meurtrier pour en parler nous
sommes en direct de tel aviv avec paula
se tailler un journaliste pour rt
internationale c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur
[Musique]
bonsoir colas laier merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france quelles
réactions en israël après que la justice
française a jugé irresponsable
pénalement le meurtrier de sara lee me
il ya eu beaucoup de colère et de
scandales
le ministre des affaires étrangères a
dit que sarah halimi a été tué car elle
était juive à cause de l'antisémitisme
il a également qualifié ce meurtre
odieux disant qu'il a fait du mal non
seulement à la victime et à sa famille
gelés également la communauté juive et à
sa capacité à se sentir en sécurité
l'avij des personnes de régis française
tout comme des israéliens en général
pense que cela met en danger les copains
tu es juif et france pour le
gouvernement français ne réussit pas à
faire face aux pannes 10 mutisme
grandissant dans ce pays justement
c'était l'une de mes questions cette
affaire est-elle de nature à impacter
d'une manière ou d'une autre l'image de
la france en israël français est en
israël et qu'il ya deux poids deux
mesures clés trop sensible
30 original et avec avec beaucoup de
villes sont commis par des personnes
pour les israéliens s'ils lancent le
front de mer à sète sur les victimes de
racisme
alors on est excusé s'il était musulman
gouvernement français ne veut pas être
accusé d'antisémitisme est un problème
croissant en france et la france les
deux juifs plutôt que de les juger
correctement que ce jugement était
n'était pas juste et qu'il faudrait
revenir sur ce cas alors il ya une
plainte en israël il va y avoir un la
soeur de sarah halimi qui espère bien la
tenue d'un nouveau procès la loi pénale
d'israël le permet quelle chance
d'aboutir et sous quels fondements de la
loi pénale israélien il est
effectivement possible d'enquêter et de
négliger c'est conférer sur des crimes
antisémites semaines à l'étranger
surtout s'ils sont dénoncés par un
citoyen de la victime et israéliennes ce
champ se battant procès c'est que dans
ce cas il est certain qu'en israël on
considère qu'il y à une nouvelle souche
attentisme en france notamment l'islam
de la jeunesse une organisation
israélienne qui a des bureaux dans le
monde entier tlusty dix ans a dit que ce
jugement était un coup il sans précédent
et établissez une jurisprudence selon
laquelle des criminels vous fait dire
qu'ils étaient fous ils étaient drogués
et qu'ils ne pouvaient donc pas être
tenu légalement responsable
ici en l'occurrence une personne a été
tuée et le criminel avec les livres à ne
pas se rendre sur les lieux du crime et
il peut certainement accroché être en
contact avec d'autres personnes juives
et il peut continuer à consommer du
cannabis la raison de ce crime
en premier lieu tout ce que vous venez
nous expliqué paula ça pousse de
nombreux juifs français a émigré en
israël pour rappel la lia il y en a de
plus en plus encore aujourd'hui les
fassions vers l'israël assez forte
depuis la france au cours des dernières
années il ya une communauté française 60
en israël et en constate également que
beaucoup de juifs français des machettes
et des appartements en israël maïs et
les villages et l'achat vologe où si
l'on peut dire car si la situation
empire en france alors qu'ils auront la
possibilité de se rendre en israël il
déploré devoir accélérer cette pièce
dure mais qu'il ne pleut pas c'est ce
déni de justice
le français allait contre la raison
d'insultés la communauté juive en france
et dans le monde ont géré par france en
fin d'année la suivre dans le monde
observe également la situation en france
et beaucoup pensent que la même chose
pourrait se reproduire dans d'autres
pays
du sport avec d'autres gouvernements et
se demande comment la entre
gouvernements réagir et merci pour la
sla fière d'avoir été avec nous en
direct de tel aviv et en france donc un
la décision de la cour de cassation dans
cette affaire et demie relance le débat
en 10 et sur la responsabilité pénale
des personnes atteintes de troubles
psychiatriques sur fond de consommation
de drogue
alors faut-il revoir la loi comme le
suggère emmanuel macron la décision
française stupéfiante comment la
comprendre c'est l'objet de notre face à
face
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
guillaume bigot et ses his own it all of
votre dernier ouvrage guillaume bigot
populo phobie paru aux éditions plon
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous à vos
côté edouard de lamaze avocat au barreau
de paris bonsoir edouard de lamaze merci
d'être avec nous alors pas de procès
donc un pour la famille de sarah demi le
meurtrier déclaré irresponsable
cette décision stupéfiante
on va dire sans mauvais jeux mots
comment la qualifier reveillez vous à
guillaume bigot
tout est encore raté dont sept dans
cette affaire c'est à dire que quand on
regarde un peu de presse qui sait ce qui
s'est passé l'instruction était déjà un
peu les évènements ou même de la police
est arrivée sur place a attendu vingt
minutes
le calvaire de cette cette pauvre madame
halimi a duré assez longtemps
ils ne sont pas intervenu parce qu'il
pensait qu'ils avaient d'ailleurs
terroriste ensuite la manière dont le
mollah mais instant ça a été a été
instruit la chambre d'instruction
apparemment il ya un refus d'accepter
les la reconstitution des événements
il ya eu aussi quand même un délai très
important pour lequel il ya une
reconnaissance de l'acte antisémite y
avoir à la fois de la folie et en même
temps l'intention de cette folie et
pouvait être antisémite c'est finalement
la conclusion à laquelle est arrivée la
chambre d'instruction
et puis enfin c'est on a l'impression de
trop ou trop peu
c'est à dire que soi et ça c'est un peu
le problème a tellement de ce jugement
mais de la loi dite bâti un qui fait
qu'il ya quand même une sorte de procès
dans le cas où les personnes sont
déclarées par par les experts
psychiatres
c'est le cas de monsieur traoré sont
déclarées irresponsables on organise
néanmoins une procès qui n'est pas un
pensait d'ailleurs une une chambre
d'instruction et il y a
reconnaissance pour les victimes et une
décision qui est prise sur
l'irresponsabilité de l'autre est en
fait finalement ça ça enfin ça crée un
sentiment d'attenté que la justice soit
soit mener jusqu'à son terme
notamment on aurait pu imaginer que le
procès en assises ait lieu et qu'il
conclut tout de même à
l'irresponsabilité de monsieur traoré
les au moins il y aurait pas eu cette
impression de déni de justice
avant que cette loi là tu existes
finalement on disait aux gens mais
finalement il y aura pas de procès parce
que l'auteur qui est complètement
irresponsable qu'on ne juge pas les
dessous ce qui peut s'entendre mais à
partir du moment où on enclenche un
dispositif de ce type
le président la république est intervenu
à plusieurs reprises dyer et a laissé à
penser à laisser accroire qu'ils
allaient y avoir un jugement est
finalement voilà on retire le tapis sous
les pieds
alors je pense que ça c'est extrêmement
frustrant rire et concluant si on va
parce qu'elle se débat en tout cas
beaucoup de réactions politiques depuis
sa décision judiciaire seront propose
parmi elles de commenter cette de marine
le pen présidente du rassemblement
national
cette décision révoltante dans la sphère
sarah halimi assassiné dans des
conditions et pour des motifs antisémite
épouvantable créé un précédent très
inquiétant edouard de lamaze révoltant
et surtout créer un précédent comme
l'écrit marine le pen c'est votre avis
également il faut d'abord voir devient
beaucoup moins ça prend quelqu'un qui ne
croit n'a pas beaucoup de métro à nos
données sur la démocratie
je crois tout d'abord que par en tant
qu'avocat mais également cuillère de
justice il ya quand même de ne pas
enchaîner par l'énormité des situations
à vienne m
l'arrêt de la production en soi n'est
pas contestable au regard de la loi tout
le monde l'a dit des gros jury selon dit
et nous communique également la cour de
cassation du stand par open uniquement
andrew donc cet arrêt de cassation pour
l'accepter comme il est avec nous n'a
que notre propre - droit d'élire ce noël
mois était à ceux qui
peut-être un peu posé des questions des
juges de questions parce que la
situation des vêtements armani les
passions versante et de droite c'est
plutôt l'origine de la situation
analysée et par conséquent c'était des
louches qui potard le mèneront battront
la nuit humaine ou perd tellement
modifié dago serein et nécessaire dans
une situation de polémiques comme celle
là donc les propos de marine le pen
bambou paraît pas de nature pouvoir et
sereine murray l'a fait et c'était
vraiment génial victime et d'un des
grands types assis et l'animation et de
la nacip de crime
je crois qu'il faut amener il ya deux
principes et soutiennent alors là c'est
l'analyse faite à dire la perte david
haccoun open l'appel doit pas être
aveugle
m regarde attaque monde et est
aujourd'hui monde et éthiques
mais où tiendra demain et toujours dans
tous les procès oui oui
le yari un petit problème de son art
jour je vous propose edouard de lamaze
de reprendre la parole dans quelques
instants edouard de lamaze qui nous
disaient voilà c'est la loi c'est vrai
qu'il ya du le droit on applique le
droit les jeux/jouets appliquer le droit
gérald darmanin nous dit le président de
la république et le garde des sceaux ont
dit qu'il fallait changer la loi les
juges appliquent la loi
elle est sûrement l'ont mal fait alors
c'est vrai que le moins qu'on puisse
dire devant la sauvagerie de ce crime
on se dit en gros guillaume bigot si on
a des envies de meurtre voilà ma foi il
suffit de fumée
un petit peu voilà deux jours avant pour
parler familièrement et on n'est pas
responsable pénalement c'est ça que ça
veut dire parce que c'est vrai que non
mais là je prend un raccourci mais
pardonnez moi c'est un petit peu
l'impression que ça donne de l'extérieur
guillaume bigot par exemple exactement
ont fait le problème c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de confusion dans cette dans
cette affaire il ya confusion entre la
notion disons de d'abolition du
discernement est altération du
discernement ou à l'abolition du
discernement
si vous prenez d'alcool et que vous
faites un accident de la route c'est une
circonstance aggravante du cloud
circonstances atténuantes votre
discernement a été a été altérée en fait
si vous êtes déclaré
on disait avant dément alors c'est plus
le terme qui est utilisé aujourd'hui les
fous vous êtes irresponsable pénalement
donc à une altération total discernement
donc un mélange des deux et à la
question de savoir où était le cursus
est ce que finalement il était raide
dingue en fait ils sont de son
discernement était totalement abolis ou
simplement altéré
ensuite la deuxième question c'est la
question des de la part de la folie la
part des stupéfiants est là aussi c'est
assez complexe parce que finalement
apparemment sur les 6,4 on dit c'est
qu'il était fou et que les stupéfiants
ont créé à accélérer le processus
ça m'est donc ce que vous que votre
question est très bonne parce qu'on a on
a laissé dans l'opinion publique cette
année d'un prêt expliqué dans cette
affaire qui est d'amener à manali de
manière calamiteuse temps par le
politique par l'officiel que finalement
c'était la prise de cannabis qui avait
conduit à cette assène à ce crime et
qu'ensuite c'est parce que comme il
avait pris du cannabis finalement la
justice avait considéré qu' il n'était
pas responsable non en fait la justice
elle s'est appuyée sur l'expertisé
psychiatrique et ça c'est vrai et c'est
tout à fait conforme à la loi et elle a
jugé que son état de santé mentale était
telle qu'il n'était plus du tout
responsable donc on ne pouvait pas le
juger c'est ça le fond de la faire donc
ça a laissé
et puis ils puiseront pourrait à mon
sens parler d'une sorte de présomption
disons de laxisme judiciaire et en
particulier à l'égard des crimes commis
par les immigrés à qui on a trouvé et
notamment les immigrés musulmans ne pas
parler de liestal ce qui a fait l'objet
d'un déni pendant des décennies en
particulier de l'islamisme qui visait
la communauté juive en france et de
l'antisémitisme islamistes donc là il ya
une sorte de fée de présomption de
laxisme de la part de l'opinion publique
à l'égard de justice on pourrait dire en
résumé que c'est tout à fait l'honneur
de la justice de résister à la pression
de l'opinion publique et de ne pas juger
un fou ça c'est tout à fait vrai mon
client n'est donnée mois ont baissé de
distribuer la parole pardonnez moi
justement cette suspicion est ce qu'il
s'agit simplement d'une décision de
justice voilà la loi est appliquée où il
y a un peu d'idéologie alors évidemment
vous allez pas me répondre à cette
question mais elle a le mérite d'être
posée parce que il ya ce soupçon là
aujourd'hui
forcément puisque au final a mis du
temps mais le caractère antisémite a été
retenu ou menace n'est pas traduit en
justice dont il ya un côté absurde entre
ces deux théories ces deux tests je les
six mois croire qu' il n'y a pas un des
magistrats de la cour de cassation qu'il
put et à boire mais eu une idée aussi
criminel ou même une absence de
reconnaissance de cette ce caractère
horrible de la cipa certainement pas ils
ont du métier qu'ils avaient à effectuer
une mission était la leur et vous pigez
français regardent la situation de
droits ils étaient offerts dans ce qui
est un peu nam nam c'est que jamais on
sait où pas renoncer ou
l'irresponsabilité retenue ne peuvent
satisfaire à la réparation civile ou
même l'association petit se porterait
hop et lui dit c'est ce n'est pas on
n'est pas là vous avez d'un côté une
décision du site wac est insatisfaisant
n'est d'accord mais qui est partie
régulière une autre côté vous avez d'air
participation des victimes et des
parties civiles
il ya eu ce titre engagé d'action en
israël on regarde l'entendre on a peur
de madame halimi et qui va demander
réparation elle est il y a deux
fondamentaux dans la justice entre la
partie civile et la représentation de
l'intérêt général et aussi il est parti
pour vingt ans non non on est parti pour
vingt ans en hôpital psychiatrique
c'est la société qui a organisé des
choses en l'état
c'est pas pour autant une partie civile
ont été réparés leur préjudice et qui ne
faille pas effectivement faire le procès
d'antisémitisme au regard de cet appel
voyez y pelé de ses poumons peuvent
vivre ensemble il faut le faire vivre
ensemble et pas l'un contre l'autre
comment bien l'entendre pour marine le
pen je vous propose avant de vous faire
réagir d'écouter la réaction de julien
bayou secrétaire nationale europe
ecologie les verts qui est plus modérée
on va dire que celle qu'on a pu entendre
au rassemblement national ou même chez
les républicains à écouter julien bayou
je comprends l'émoi de la communauté
juive mais on doit conserver ce principe
on ne juge pas les fous la justice ce
n'est pas la vengeance
alors guillaume vidot il ya plusieurs
choses qui attire l'attention c'est vrai
que julien bayou qui semble résumer cet
émoi la communauté juive c'est assez
étonnant vous avez le sentiment qu'avec
les juifs qui ont été choqués dans cette
affaire aujourd'hui en france non non tu
tiens ce serait totalement totalement
inacceptable donc je répète en fait
c'est ça qui te plaît c'est difficile à
comprendre tout acte antisémite entrant
ce n'est pas que la terre la communauté
vu que c'est la terre du cac communauté
nationale
comme tout islamophobe d'ailleurs non ce
qui est ce qui est difficile à
comprendre c'est qu'il ya une
irresponsabilité sans doute de l'auteur
sans doute un pic à soi même mais et que
simultanément cette se fout finalement
n'a pas
dillon diriger sa folie de par hasard il
l'a dirigé par ce qu'il a été nourrie
par un antisémitisme islamique qui se
diffuse ce qui est très largement
malheureusement diffusé dans d'autres
pays et que voilà ça après styliste on
attend quelque sorte
il ya une folie si vous voulez dans un
autre cas dans un autre cas on arrive à
la ce type était était dingue
donc on ne peut pas le juger fallait
d'un ça c'est très simple à comprendre
mais là il ya eu la pollution par le
cannabis a laissé le cannabis qui a
déclenché sa bombe et non il était fou
et deuxièmement il ya la question dans
le sémitisme et je pense que soit il ne
fallait pas du tout mettre le doigt dans
un quelque sorte un an un engrenage
judiciaire mais la loi dati l'obligeait
finalement et donc ça a créé une attente
de procès et puis il ya une sorte de
coït interrompu l'année passée en effet
plus de français à être rentré chez vous
ici il est irresponsable et monsieur a
tout à fait raison c'est conforme à la
loi mais c'est complètement absurde en
fait donc soit il était d'un conte le
gypaète à l'opinion auraient pu
comprendre
soit il fallait le renvoyer par la cour
d'assises évidemment et là on aurait dû
avoir le procès peut-être cannabis qui
est surtout le procès plus grave un
véritable procès si vous voulez
peut-être on aurait pu le déclarer à la
fois irresponsable lui est considéré
qu'il y a il admettre qu'il y à un
ancien mitis mme denat turkistani qui se
propage dans le pays et qui est très
grave et qu'il aurait qui est je pense
que dans un procès évidemment juge un
homme on juge un fait aux riches dfm il
ya toujours un retentissement politique
sociale à un procès c'est normal il faut
l'accepter d'ailleurs est donc là
vraiment on a l'impression que la
magistrature le nom de j sierre s'est
recroquevillé sur lui même a voulu
appliquer de manière extrêmement
tatillonne les textes sans comprendre la
portée politique de cette affaire
et maintenant la portée politique est
encore plus grand
parce que là il y aura probablement
c'est la loi israélienne la possibilité
d'enclencher un procès mais comme la
france n'extrade pas ses nationaux
alors on va se retrouver en situation de
protéger ce type triste aussi un
épouvantable personnage même s'il est
fou en tout cas il est manifestement en
plus d'être fou islamistes et
antisémites au dernier degré et donc on
va le on va le protéger enfin goyer qui
ça fait monter le communautarisme et ça
crée une situation qui est vraiment très
très délétère mètres de la base le mot
de la fin pour vous la justice n'a pas
pris la mesure de justement de ce
retentissement politique et emmanuel
macron à une raison d'une certaine
manière de siffler si je puis dire la
fin de la récréation
en tout cas de demander que la loi
change voilà je crois que la suisse a
parfaitement compris ce qu'elle faisait
elle a parfaitement pris conscience et
je connais pour konaté juge quand même
de ces hauts magistrats de notre france
et qui n'ont rien d'antisémite ce soit
yoga plein et on le voit à travers tout
pour décision tombait conscience du peu
de pouvoir qu'ils avaient de la
nécessité d'analyser le droit au regard
de cette rapport expertise dos un seul
l'essai à doute sur la capacité
d'aliénation de l'acte dont vous voyez
on est dans une situation kafkaïenne et
ne faisons pas d'amalgamé moi je crois
que ce qui est fondamental c'est de
continuer à garder la personnalisation
de la peine l'individuation de la peine
chaque personne à droite étaient jugés
en fonction de sa personnalité
si cette personnalité est insupportable
comme elle l'est et précieux à raison
comme elle l'est pour la nation toute
entière au nom de l'antisémitisme eh
bien il ya d'autres tribunaux qui vont
pouvoir le juger et le déclarer mais pas
lorsqu'on étudie la la peine en tant que
tel un regard d'un texte de loi voté au
nom du peuple français changerons le
texte
les magistrats rendront une autre
décision du confort peut-être à
l'émotion justifié d'aujourd'hui
peut-être à la règle la morale et de
l'éthique nationale mais la situation
allait comme ça n'allait pas
n'est pas satisfaisante mais n'est pas
authentique art comme elle les
spectacles merci edouard de lamaze
guillaume bigot d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france et c'est la fin
de cette émission se retrouve dans
quelques instants pour un point complet
sur l'actualité
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine millions eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent